welcome to the michaela peterson podcast
this is episode 14.
for today's episode i spoke with cole
robinson
i've had a lot of people ask me to
interview cole he's the inventor of the
snake diet
the snake diet is a method of extended
fasting and feasting
he's helped thousands of people lose
weight who haven't been helped by anyone
else
i think he's a pioneer in fasting and
weight loss
please be warned this is not a
kid-friendly podcast
this may not even be an adult friendly
podcast depending on the adult
cole is crude i think he's hilarious
he's probably one of the most ridiculous
no
he's probably the most ridiculous person
i've ever spoken with
i've followed him online for at least
the last year and a half and i've seen
his youtube videos
they're loud and crass and rude but man
does he help motivate people and
wow does he ever see results he gets
absolutely destroyed by the mainstream
news because he's ridiculously extreme
but he's saved lives i hope you enjoy
this podcast
we cover fasting the importance of salt
how to consume a ridiculous number of
calories and stay lean
tricks on how to stay fit how to lose
weight ridiculously fast
cole has gained weight just to show
people how to lose it and he's done
things like
lose 20 pounds in three days of dry
fasting
we talk about what people should
generally eat and why he screams at
people in his youtube videos
hope you can stand this podcast
[Music]
paul robinson welcome to my podcast
thanks for having me on
it's so nice to hear a canadian accent
yeah i guess you guys are from canada
aren't you that's right
yeah my dad my dad's from alberta okay
okay
we used to go out there in the summer
okay where is he from
um he was born in edmonton okay that's
where i'm at yeah in edmonton
yeah he grew up by in fairview
yeah that's pretty redneck
that's pretty [ __ ] bad yeah yeah i
went there in the winter one time it
wasn't great
yeah i worked there before when i was
still you know
doing the instrumentation and
yeah it's [ __ ] redneck as hell that's
that's very strong
it's funny uh so we should probably just
get started by if you could give
my audience a bit of an intro about who
you are and what it is that you do
that'd be good okay to sum it up i
i help people with weight loss mainly
you know just general health and fitness
and i help people teach people how to be
eating addictions if there is such a
thing i guess more it's a lot of times
it's
it's life issues that lead to eating i
believe but i help people
teach people how to fast okay i've done
all sorts of different types of long
fast dry fasting i'll
promote that i promote fasting on salt
water which should be the snake juice
um all sorts of fasting routines i
i help people beat health issues you
know i've dealt people with people
mostly obesity but you know you got
cancer diabetes all
all the [ __ ] right and then i'll use all
different types of
macro routines and diet routines
you know cut carbs carbs like i deal
with guys with performance
uh sprinters anything anything anything
i i just
i just build a lifestyle around fasting
the one thing that's always common with
me
is the fasting focus lifestyle some
people fast longer than others if
they're
super fat i'll have people fast i don't
really promote anything anymore longer
than seven days
but also and then i'll have like the
performance guys you know i'll even have
guys do two meals a day
you know no snacks um it all depends
what their goal is depends what their
goal is
right you know i just build something
around the goal and the goal change
maybe they're 500 pounds and they get
down to 300 and now they're walking more
now they gotta maybe eat a little more
often you know so we'll just adjust it
accordingly right
so how did you get into or learn about
these extended fasts
so i was a fitness trainer at one point
and i was basically training mostly
women
and it was always the same [ __ ]
[ __ ] right you know
people just can't stop eating and the
one girl
i challenged her to a 24-hour fast and
at that point i didn't even know if
fasting was healthy i had some surgeries
you know everyone's had a few
surgeries or they ate a fast for a day
or whatever before they knocked you out
on an aesthetic
and uh when she did the 24 hours i did
i actually did basically two days and i
knew
nothing about ketosis or ketogenic diets
or
like nothing i thought i didn't even
think it was healthy like i knew muslims
drive faster like that's ludicrous
you know but i just get it because i
knew 24-hour fast isn't gonna [ __ ]
kill her right like
and she just you know so i just went a
little longer than her
and then at that point i actually
started eating a meal a day
and just my personality it escalated
because i'm always digging for the truth
because you know now we now i know i can
eat a meal a day
and make gains in the gym so now what
other [ __ ] are they telling us right
but then i started doing then i pushed
it i think within two weeks of doing a
meal a day i'm like okay let's try a 72
hour fast
and i did the 72 and
i ran out of gas on the third day i was
in the gym doing some deadlifts and such
and i ran out of gas that was before i
got into the salt
and then one thing led to another i was
experimenting with some guy
with a with a fat young guy he's fat and
we're trying to cut water off i'm using
salt and all this other [ __ ] and
that's when i realized that salt was the
trick to do the long fast and feel good
and then i did a longer fast on a pile
of salt water for seven days and i was
fine and that's when i realized well
there's a crack the code to not eating
you just basically you can do it on salt
water very easily then after that i got
into dry fasting as well because
there's always places for that too it
depends how screwed up somebody is maybe
they have really bad skin issues and
like a dry fast is a pure fast right so
i will use that as a health tool
i don't use that for people that are
just trying to like
get fit or lose weight a lot of times
i'll use that when somebody's like
really sick right
does that naturally i believe that when
you're really sick your body tells you
not to even drink anything
just like when a dog gets hit by a car
or something they go hide in the bush
and dry fast until it's healed up
and i think we're kind of the same way i
don't know if you've mentioned autophagy
you know when you're talking about just
healing and killing old cells and kind
of cleansing the body dry fasting is
pretty aggressive that way so i've done
seven days no water food
right and i've done i've done a fast on
the snake juice like the snake juice is
just
essentially sodium potassium and some
basic electrolytes right
i've done like 10 days straight on snake
juice and then five days dry so it's 15
total
that i i was i started doing these long
fasts
originally it was pure weight loss okay
because at the end of the day the
most important thing to basically fix is
being a fat ass because a lot of people
will be like oh my thyroid or all this
[ __ ] i'm like are you fat
and then again i'm like well shut the
[ __ ] up and stop eating and start moving
right
because you know what i mean like that's
like the leading
it's gonna be like the leading health
risk is just being obese
so i was i was always fasting to
motivate people to not be afraid of
not eating essentially so i did it
myself right so i
i would do fast just to show them and i
like that 15 day fast i lost 35 pounds
and
you know i i think i was down i was i
had
like i don't know i think i had 10
pounds left to dump and i i needed to
like show them that i could lose 35 in
two weeks so i did a five day dry fast
just
to get up to get the weight off you know
like i've just done all sorts of
hardcore stuff and that's how i figured
out that salt water
you know just experimenting with salts
and understanding that the body needs
salt
yeah okay so i've done i i've seen
your seven day drive fast video which is
intense and i'll
link it uh in this youtube video uh
so i've tried dry fasting and i've only
done i think i've done 36 hours or
something and then
i've decided that doing it with salt
water was way easier for me
well doing 36 hours isn't so bad for dry
fast that's that's not so bad but
anything
further than that does not make me feel
very good so i started experimenting
with
salt fast and i know for your snake
juice recipe
it's way higher in potassium than what i
do
so i'm wondering why you decided to go
so much higher on potassium than
so the way it works like i've done so
much experimentation just
obviously you learn it depends on the
person how fat they are right
but if you want to get into talking
about like those two salts
potassium is going to be fairly fixed
so let's say on the day depending how
active you are
if you're getting in maybe 2500 to
5000 milligrams or something like a
fairly fixed number
but the sodium has to be if you're
really obese and you're trying to walk
and you're sweating like i'll go
like okay i'll i'll tell you right now i
don't want to kill any of your viewers
but that sodium i run this or i'll run
12
000 milligrams of sodium in the day and
that's me
eating like 6 000 calories
like strict 20 80 keto
with like well not strict keto like
maybe 100 grams of fruit
but about a 20 80 ratio and assaults
through the roof
and like i have the girl even at the
house right now
you know she's walking quite a bit now
we've dropped like she's dropped like i
don't know
a pile of way in the last week or two
but i got her taken
probably six to eight thousand
milligrams a day
so essentially snake juice essentially
the snake juice
is mainly like if you're fairly
sedentary which i hope you're not you
should be standing all day excited when
you get into that
important it's just not sick sitting is
the worst thing in the world
but the snake juice essentially is
mainly a potassium supplement it's easy
it's sodium
okay sodium's easy to get it's free it's
cheap you can
get whatever pink salt whatever you want
but the potassium i have a bitumen time
some
people can't get it so you've got pink
juice basically i got the ratio about
one to one
so like say if you were going to do a
straight fast just on the on the packets
you might take like three in the day but
if you're gonna like be super active you
just make sure you have like a can of
sodium too like a can of just
you know sodium chloride regular salt
and just hammer that back because
you're you're never gonna just you're
not gonna sell that as a supplement it's
salt right you know what i mean
like people just got to understand that
that
essentially as long as you keep your
sodium nice and high like with you
that's why you get away
that's why most people get away the
lower potassium number like even me the
potassium on the day might be 5 000
but if the sodium is up around eight or
ten thousands i'm sweating like a pig
you know biking or whatever all day long
then as long as the sodium is high
you won't dump potassium so what happens
when people sweat like when people are
moving
and they're fasting and they're actually
trying to move if you
lose all your potential if you lose all
the sodium because you didn't keep it up
then you will dump everything else
that's the problem right
so as long as the sodium is really high
then
you'll you'll hold the rest of it fairly
well on a fairly long fast and you'll
feel good
and how do you know if your sodium is
high enough i actually get people
if they they want to make damn sure
taste your piss like just dip your
finger in your piss
if your piss tastes a hint salty you're
good
if the if the piss tastes like flat and
you're feeling like [ __ ]
and you're holding water so this is the
other thing like say with yourself or
with
a really obese woman and she gets crazy
low on sodium
so essentially she's dumped everything
so now she's low on everything
the sodium she'll start guzzling water
it's classic they'll start
guzzling water because their bodies like
wants the salt
but there's nothing there so they're
guzzling water and there's a hormone
called aldosterone
that'll make you try to re like hold on
to water because
you're trying to get salt but there's
nothing there so then you'll blow it up
and you'll hold all this water weight so
that's
one of the reasons why a lot of people
are holding all this water weight when
they fast
or when they're doing strict like 20 80
keto or even lower than 20 on the
protein because
your insulin is low and you'll dump salt
like like a son of a [ __ ]
and they don't keep sodium up and
they're scared of [ __ ] sodium right
they're scared of sodium they're scared
of cholesterol they're scared of sodium
because all the [ __ ]
so you crank up that sodium and then you
have energy like crazy when you're on a
fast
right and so most people like i say if
you
if most people think that sodium makes
you hold water which is actually
[ __ ] so what'll happen
say you take somebody like yourself
you're on the fast the sodium gets low
and you're drinking a bunch of fresh
water just because you
weren't getting enough sodium or didn't
know any better you'll blow it up
but then what'll happen i come along and
i'm like michaela
taste your pits you're like uh it
doesn't taste like [ __ ] all but water
so then i'm like crank so then i'll have
you cranking sodium for like two days
straight like
big like big volumes like maybe getting
you taken six to eight thousand
throughout the day so you don't get
diarrhea
and then you'll taste your urine in a
day and a half and it's taste salty
then what happens is you start dropping
the water
because now your body's like a happy
again and it starts unloading that water
weight
you might blow it up at the start for
like a couple days because you're
cranking the sodium with water but
that's why you can almost dry salt load
somewhat too if you know you're holding
water you can actually just knock the
salt in your mouth you don't want to do
that with potassium because it'll burn
your
burn your skin but you can definitely
throw some sodium in your mouth
and and kind of you can mix it very very
concentrated
right just you don't want to give
yourself diarrhea but then that's how
you drop water
and then at that point keep the salt
really high especially like somebody
like you if you're eating
you know strict carnivore
or like especially if it's keto
carnivore so keto
the macros are like low protein high fat
which most people are [ __ ]
up but you want the salt high really
high
you want to be like just a salty [ __ ]
you know what i mean you just want to be
salty
no you really like if you should be able
to
feel the salt burn your eyes when you
sweat you should taste it if it drips on
your tongue off your nose if you're
sweating
but the urine never lies most people
won't do it like maybe you know but you
just taste that that's how you know
and that's why that's when you'll feel
good because i know most people they'll
be on a fast
they'll hit about day three because they
came off some carbs and they're holding
lots of salt
and they start dumping salt because they
get into ketosis usually it takes about
36 to 48 hours
uh type 2 diabetic which i will say the
people that are watching this they're
type 2 diabetics you're just a [ __ ]
fat pig
the type 2 diabetes is a joke right it's
just your liver is fatty
lose weight and you'll heal right but
sometimes their blood sugar is elevated
to the point
like if they're running a really high
blood sugar because they can't
they can't clear it fast enough they
might take like
72 hours to get into ketosis because it
takes a while for the body to chew up
that blood sugar
i've seen people that were extreme that
have actually took
four days to get into ketosis they were
basically
because their blood sugar was so high
like 400
in your units you might be used to using
those units or maybe
if we're talking the other other units
uh like
200 through like 200 uh or
sorry like 20 millim millimoles per
liter
20 right or like milligrams per
deciliter you're talking if you're
talking like 200
those high high numbers but that takes
them that long to chew the blood sugar
down right
then they get into ketosis then they
start feeling good because they go
through those sugar withdrawals and then
now they're just burning straight body
fat
wow that was a lot of information do you
actually do people
actually come to you and then you
convince them to test to taste their
urine does that happen
yeah i do because they've been like
because i had some massive [ __ ] ups at
fat camp here because i got a house that
i rented i have two girls here
and the one girl earlier this winter had
a real [ __ ] up
because they just i told her to drink
her snake juice
and it wasn't happening and they took it
for granted and it catches you
it doesn't catch you right away but it
catches you
like if you're as big as her you might
be holding a fair amount of salt but
it'll catch you especially if you start
moving
and sweating and all of a sudden when it
does catch you it's already too late now
you're so freaking low on salt that she
started having like
crazy pain in her feet because the
sodium was so low she started getting
cramps in her feet to the point where oh
yeah
yeah you know so it's it's very
simple like to not confuse people if you
fast
you want to hit a good amount of
potassium the
the recommended rda is 4 700 milligrams
so if you're between 25 and that
maybe 25 and 5 000 on the day which is
going to be about a teaspoon
to two teaspoons of potassium chloride
powder
right or like with the snake juice that
snake juice packed weed that's got
a thousand milligrams of potassium in it
so let's say
on the day for your average woman you
might get two packets if you're going to
take those packs and then the sodium
is variable depending on activity so you
crank the sodium
up like 4 000 is not going to be high
and even though the recommended rda is
low as hell i forget exactly it is maybe
2
200 or some [ __ ] it's like it's a joke
it should be like especially fasting
because your insulin drops you kick salt
like crazy
and you want to be at four thousand five
thousand six thousand
just dip your finger in your urine it's
easiest to check it that way and if you
taste a hint of salt you're good
if the salt taste fades away you're
probably low and you got to crank the
salt up
somebody who watches this is going to do
that i'm sure
well it's all you always know right like
it's especially if you're talking like
people i deal with like i deal with
people that are 600 pounds
yeah so that's not a joke like this so
this
might sound crazy but the big girl
that's at the house here
um she so her fat her youtube channel's
uh 500 pound fasting lady and her name's
maya
and she i had her load on 10
000 milligrams of salt for a week every
day
and she she was 430 pounds and most
people like that's ludicrous well you're
going to give her a heart attack like
it's [ __ ] right she was that low so
i just i told her to
and i didn't care about the bloating
that would happen in the beginning
because she's taking it with water
so a good a good rule of thumb
you want to be probably about 2
000 milligrams per liter of water that
you drink
or liter of fluid so let's say you are
eating a diet that's like you know your
regular
regular diet where you're like meat and
some fruit or whatever
for even the fruit would count as fluid
so ballparking it you'd be about 2 000
milligrams per liter of
fluid so if you're eating strict keto
and you're only really drinking water
your
whatever say you put 2 000 milligrams on
your food
or you have 2 000 milligrams of sodium
in your food and not be equal to
you know then you drink about a liter of
water right but on a straight fast
there's no food
obviously so you'd be like you know for
every liter of water 2 000 milligrams
would be
going to be a good point to start at if
you're pissed taste super salty you can
cut it back
and that's how i do it because that then
that's that's an old old like even to
all you mentioned is they make even stan
efforting promotes that same ratio
and there's a whole article if you look
up on t nation actually when i started
fasting that was the original article
that a buddy of mine sent me
to try to cut water weight off this fat
kid i was helping
and that's how it all started and that
teenage that article talks about
the sultans i think it's called the salt
your secret weapon
now even four years ago i found that
article and athlete coaches were having
these guys
make sure they get in 2 000 milligrams
for every liter of water
and some of them are drinking four or
five liters a day so that's like eight
ten thousand milligrams right
way higher than people would think right
and that's a lot of
reason why people feel like [ __ ] like we
need sodium
but most people now if you're completely
sedentary
obviously it's going to be less water
too right so
if you're only drinking one liter of
water in the day then you're only
getting two thousand milligrams of
sodium because you're not sweating
because you're sitting on your ass
so yeah mike's that's funny my
experience with a carnivore diet and i
went
from paleo to like keto
to carnivore uh and my salt
was a disaster probably for five months
on carnivore and i didn't know
that it was an issue i was salting the
hell
out of my steaks but i wasn't adding any
to my water and i was
so thirsty like there were days i was
drinking seven liters of water and i
didn't realize i was
just missing salt trying to drink salt
with unsalted water and that's where
most people are screwing it up because
even sometimes like i don't know
i i kind of my diet right now i'll go
like
sunday zero carb on a meal some days
i'll go
two big meals with a little bit of fruit
you know like i'll
i'll kind of bounce in and out of
ketosis all the time
you know and it depends on coaching
maybe i'll even have them eat a bunch of
carbs if they want that
real explosive strength but
the salt like you said if i was eating
like a couple ribeye steaks on a night
or something like that
like you think you're dousing them with
salt it's not enough
yeah we're talking if you okay like if
you're eating like a kilo
or say 800 grams of steak and you're
some guy i've seen 800 grams of ribeye
steak it's probably about 2400 calories
or something like that
like you should be probably putting like
taking two actual teaspoons of sodium
and dumping it on the steak
you know like most people aren't even
close and you have to be really high
when you go low carb
because as soon as you go low carb or
keto
or now this is where people [ __ ]
up the carnivore diet though too because
i
know i've done experiments with eating a
crazy amount of meat
and you can definitely elevate the [ __ ]
on your blood sugar with me
yes i ate five kilos of steak one night
in one sitting
and my blood sugar was elevated a full
point for like 14 hours i
checked it every hour so that's why some
of these carnivore people
there i believe like if you're trying to
get the best health aspect you want to
make a truly
keto carnivore if you're trying to do it
that way which is going to be
20 80 macros as soon as you start going
over 20
your protein is too [ __ ] high and
especially if you're trying to cut on
carnivore
we're trying to drop the calories down
now you're getting into basically a
rabbit starvation style diet where the
protein sky high and there's no fat
that's the whole point you keep the fat
and salt high it kills hunger
that's the only way to truly kill hunger
is a crazy amount of salt
high fat low protein will kill hunger
and that's why i use that
just a tool i use you know it's not like
i have everybody eating that way but
that works
very well for your average fat person
that's eating every fourth or fifth or
sixth or
seventh day i'll just eat a basically
bacon works perfect
like i don't care about all the [ __ ]
the nitrates and [ __ ] i don't [ __ ]
care i care about weight loss
so whatever works if they're gonna eat a
pack of johnsonville
sausages and they're hitting my salt
count and they're hitting my fat and
protein count
and they're losing like 50 pounds a
month if they're 400 pounds
do that until you have no weight left to
lose then you can screw around with your
diet once you're down at a proper body
weight right
i think when i started incorporating
salt into my diet when i first started
fasting
when i finally figured out that you
needed to have salt water
i think the first day in order to not
get a headache and not get brain fog i
think i had 12 grams of
salt i know it's way down
yeah if you're that low you know i had
one time
where i had 18 000 milligrams
in like my weight i believe this is how
i figured out dry fast and it's funny
you do one experiment that leads you to
the other
but i so i had the young the kid that
was like 300 pounds i'm trying to cut
him and i have him
taking all this salt and we're doing 48
hour fast on straight meat actually
and i'm like well if he's doing all this
salt i better do something and i feel
guilty right so one night i pounded back
18 000 milligrams of sodium
and my weight went from 164 pounds up to
178
in like four hours i was so loaded up
i was so bloated up that my vans and my
forward were popping out and i had
like a headache for six hours but then
i had a power lifting me coming up in
like five days
and i'm like [ __ ] i'm not gonna make
weight for this meat i need to be 163
but i'm not an idiot i knew that it was
just water so that's when i did my first
dry fast and i didn't even need to dry
fast i didn't drink water for three days
and i just pissed out all the water
right so that's why i figured
so it's just one thing always leads to
another you know what i mean like you
you experiment and learn
this is probably something i shouldn't
tell my audience but when i um
i'm i was i'm super strict carnivore
because i've got autoimmune
an autoimmune condition that is
controlled by it but i went out to eat
when i was still
super sensitive to spices and things and
i got hit at a restaurant and i didn't
know what they put on the stake
and i went back and i was like how do i
make myself puke i don't want this
in my body i don't know what it is and i
had i
i like one of my friends texted me and
they're like don't didn't james bond
take like a tablespoon of salt or like
and just and that makes you puke yeah
well it turns out that doesn't make
everybody puke and i i i i feel like
crazy
i thought i was gonna die like i i've
never had a migraine
like that i feel like i could feel my
brain separating from my skull
and i was just like i deserve this yeah
yeah even for people watching this so i
always tell
people like you know obviously we got
the snake juice packets and people can
buy but i always tell them you can go to
the grocery store and make your own
[ __ ] snape juice right just go buy
the salt and make it
and you can do whatever you want so i
had a girl
this is way back and of course it's
always
always the easy [ __ ] road always
leads you down the bad results
so of course you didn't like to taste
the potassium powder mixed in the water
so she threw it in some plastic capsules
and started telling me that she had a
stomachache
right so i of course i'm like well
i tried it so i took like 5 000
milligrams of potassium in plastic
capsules
and within like 15 minutes i had the
but not just a gut egg it felt like
something was burning a hole in my gut
and i went in the bathtub and i probably
should have tried to puke
because then i would have got it out of
my gut real quick and i did and i'm
laying on the floor and at the fetal
position and my
at the time i was living with my buddy
and i'm like i thought maybe he's gonna
have to take me to the hospital get my
stomach pumped
and what i ended up doing i did is so
don't
[ __ ] put potassium chloride powder in
a [ __ ] capsule and take it
always mix it with water or you will
[ __ ] give yourself a [ __ ] stomach
ulcer
all right so i gave myself a stomach
ulcer and i was and i tried
everything so i was in pain like you
know
and if i i need a big meal you know all
the [ __ ]
[ __ ] on the internet how to do
something with an ulcer like
you know coconut water [ __ ] bananas
all this [ __ ]
and it's like well how the hell am i
gonna fast to actually try to heal if i
gotta chronically eat this food just to
keep the pain because
as soon as the food's out of your
stomach the stomach acid hits that ulcer
because people people understand how
stomach works you got like your mucus
lining
and that protects your stomach from the
stomach acid
right so if you got a hole there the
acid now is burning the [ __ ] actual
stomach lining
so what happened i [ __ ] it was digging
deep and i found this
but this is [ __ ] unbelievable if
anybody's watching this as [ __ ]
ulcers or ulcerative colitis or anything
i found a write-up about a guy
who had ulcers for like 20 years and he
was great he tried to kill himself one
night when his wife
was at work and she got rid of all the
sleeping pills and [ __ ]
and he they had a whole bunch of cayenne
pepper and in this
in the cabinet in the bathroom and he
pounded all this cayenne pepper thing to
kill him
and he put like a pillow over his face
he was talking about this and then
the next day his wife actually had to
wake him up was the first time he swept
in like 20
years and so i read this and i start
digging endo
the reason why because that capsaicin
creates like mucus
and it almost acts as a local anesthetic
on the open sore in your gut
so then i was like well this sounds
[ __ ] ludicrous but i'm going to try
it over to the health food store went
and bought a bunch of high test
uh cayenne pepper capsules and again i
don't take the capsules
ever i open them up dump the [ __ ] in the
water and drink it right
and i [ __ ] i was scared shitless because
i was fasted and i'm like okay well
let's try an empty stomach see what
happens and
i drank probably you know two capsules
full and about 500 ml of water
instantly probably within five minutes
the pain was [ __ ] gone
and i'm like unbelievable and then so
what i did is i just fasted for about
three days on cayenne pepper
and that's how i started throwing the
cayenne pepper in the salt water
and i and then also yeah and so i healed
the ulcer
in like three [ __ ] days with fasting
and cayenne pepper it was unbelievable
unbelievable like i was in pain i
thought i was gonna have this for the
rest of my life
because there's people that just don't
want to cure an ulcer right
and that's how and then the cayenne
pepper obviously cranks your metabolism
up so when you're fasting
if you're faster than snake juice or
salt water or whatever
can pepper if you can handle it you know
if it cranks so much [ __ ] on your
metabolism you can see you dilate your
blood vessels it's excellent for you
right if you can handle it
but like you say i do use strict
carnivore as a tool
when people have [ __ ] up stomachs or
maybe from antibiotics or
whatever right i'll and obviously i get
people to pull coffee i'm [ __ ] like
110
against [ __ ] coffee i've experimented
with coffee to the extreme
and it doesn't give you nothing positive
the benefits completely the negatives
completely outweigh the benefits like 20
like ten to one
right like so because that causes a lot
of stomach problems when you get like 40
years old these coffee addicts
get a hold of me and we start eating
food and they can digest [ __ ] all
and they can't have proper bowel
movements so they're like reliant on the
coffee that bowel movements plus they're
[ __ ]
because it drops your hcl levels right
it drops your stomach your natural hdl
levels because it's
it's so acidic naturally then it makes
it so your body's like huh
i don't need to produce my own acid
anymore kind of like a guy that takes
tests
you know it's like huh your balls are
like oh i guess we don't have to produce
testosterone anymore because he's
hitting tests
so your balls shrivel up right same idea
so like coffee and not just that it
[ __ ] your rem sleep and your beach
sleep cycle that's why
i'm like number one sleep sleep is
number one if you don't get in your
sleep
i don't care what you're doing your
[ __ ] lifestyle sucks if you can't
sleep you gotta fix
that first sleep and then exercise and
diet like that's
you know so you start with sleep
sleep is interesting it's number one
because you won't heal nothing if you
can't sleep it doesn't matter if you're
like obviously you'll see some results
from from a diet that's working for you
and fasting
even if your sleep is still shitty
there's no doubt because i deal with
nurses that are working shift work and
sleep like [ __ ] but
if you can get your sleep in check
that's when you
really heal up so whatever it takes to
get your sleeping bag so
you know get up at six go to bed at ten
rise and sleep with the sunlight right
like dark your runoff oh like get rid of
all the noise
like i do not break my sleep for
anything anymore anything period like i
don't give a [ __ ] at [ __ ]
the biggest celebrity in the world wanna
do a podcast with me i will not
[ __ ] break my [ __ ] sleep for it it
has to be on my clock
because i know how i feel and when you
get very used to
feeling that good you just feel like
[ __ ] it's almost like when i still used
to be a pissed tank drunk years ago
it's like you're used to having
hangovers
so then when you now like a hangover
just kill me because
i'm not used to it but then back then
you had one every week so it's like ah
it doesn't it's the norm
but once you feel this good like most
people don't
know it feels like [ __ ] feel good
they don't you know they don't
know what it feels like to be like elite
level
not a lead that's like talking
athleticism but like that top top level
of health
they just don't understand what it feels
like to really have a good
sleep that's why a lot of people that
drink a lot of coffee
they're like oh i slept good you don't
know the [ __ ] feels like the [ __ ]
sleep good if you're a coffee addict
you just don't until you actually cut
the coffee
long enough that you have a real natural
sleep and then you will understand what
i'm talking about how good
a deep sleep feels where you wake up
when you've slept so deeply that like
you're [ __ ] drooling on the side of
your face like you're almost in a coma
right you know what i mean vaguely i
don't think i've slept very well for at
least eight months
before that though i was pretty good
before that and it made
an amazing difference i never took sleep
seriously
i didn't at all it was always diet and
then i started getting my sleep wake
cycle
scheduled every day exactly the same
and it made a huge difference to my mood
and i've noticed that
the doomy feelings i get when i travel
and i get jet lag
that weird doomy feeling is sleep
deprivation which i didn't
know before yeah and you really
so here's what i will say to you and
like people that are watching about
if you push your body with exercise
that'll expose where you're weak so
let's say even like just standing
or like i'm a very big promoter of
standing time now
because of helping these extreme obese
people that can't even walk
you people just don't understand how
important it is to not
sit standing all day you'll you'll burn
an extra 800 to 1000 calories just not
sitting
and then that lets you eat more which
cranks up your metabolism because food
does
does drive metabolism food plus the burn
so eat and burn like exercising food
drives metabolism so if you want to get
really good shape
and you're way out of shape just start
by getting in
crazy standing time doesn't even have to
be walking
just not sitting sitting is the [ __ ]
worst
plus it's terrible for your digestion
terrible because
we were never meant to be in a seated
position we're meant to lie
just being here i can see you're
standing and i'm feeling bad
yeah like i don't sit i don't sit like i
even ride a bmx bike and not a mountain
bike now
like i might have a mountain bike this
winter again if i try to because i'm
gonna maybe try to just go
no car life right so i'm just gonna ride
in alberta
yeah in the winter yeah i've done it
before
like years ago i [ __ ] got an impaired
like when i was a kid drunk driving and
i actually had to drive ride a bike and
a winner
but then now when i write a bmx and i
[ __ ] everybody thinks i'm a [ __ ]
drunk like i think people on bmx now are
[ __ ] drug dealers
it's [ __ ] up who comes up to you
asking for lighters and drugs and [ __ ]
but anyway i the bmx though the seat is
on the bike but it's so low i don't sit
like i just do not sit on the seat at
all
like even when i coast i just stand so
like but you'll you'd be blown away
and this is where people talk about
detoxing and [ __ ]
it's called move your [ __ ] ass
because once you're moving your
lymphatic system that's how you detox
you don't got to do all this crazy
tea i'm a big diet is important as [ __ ]
all right
but i'll tell you right now if some fat
ass came to me and wanted help
and we didn't even i didn't even make
them make a diet
change like let's say i didn't tell them
to do nothing
but stand all day
naturally they will lose so much weight
it would make your head spin because as
soon as they're standing all day
they're not eating you're not eating and
standing
see when people eat it's like this
[ __ ] big tradition
it's like they they they cook their
[ __ ] sausage and potatoes or whatever
and they're like they sit down
and they completely kill their their
momentum on the day and they sit like i
stand and eat it's like eating go
eat and go right and they completely
kill their momentum and now they're just
sitting on their [ __ ]
ass till till they go to bed right
but if you stand all the time you get
and plus
it makes you not even want to eat anyway
for like because you'll be seeing
results so quick
but then you throw in the good proper
diet throw in the fasting
throw in some some tracking of actual
food volume like calorie counting
and then you see crazy results because
expanding the amount of calories you
will burn
one hour of standing is a hundred if
you're a regular sized person like me
maybe and if you're a fat ass that's 300
pounds four pounds 500 pounds
you're talking massive calorie burn
standing when i made the girl that's
living here stand for like an
hour it's like me sprinting for an hour
because she's like 400
500 pounds like try putting 300 pounds
on your back and staying there
like you're burning 300 400 calories
it's insane
people just underestimate standing they
people think that they've got to do all
this [ __ ] [ __ ]
to get in shape when they just gotta
be consistent day to day and start with
just not sitting down
because not sitting gives you momentum
to now walk
or jog but at minimum don't sit and then
throw in your
you know your sprints if you want to do
some sprints or go for a hike and [ __ ]
but
at minimum do not sit like you know
there's that no fat movement
like i should start no [ __ ]
you know
yeah i can see okay so for anyone who
hasn't seen
cole's youtube videos i don't think i've
seen a you
i think this might be one of the few
youtube videos that goes up that
isn't him yelling at the camera
so i asked my instagram some questions
because a lot of people who follow me
also follow you
and so i'm going to shoot some of their
questions over but one of them
one of them was why scream at people
aren't you worried it's gonna turn
people off
because you know what that's a very good
question
when i yell at people you know
that the people that are gonna actually
follow me
and do what i want to do are not [ __ ]
[ __ ] so then what happens let's say
let's say like put in a context with
numbers let's say there's a million
people
and i'm so hardcore that only out of a
million people
a thousand people love me
those thousand will get amazing results
the other people that were bitching and
complaining about me [ __ ] calling
them fat pig
those people are gonna be useless anyway
and they're not gonna [ __ ] get a
result
but you know what happens the thousand
that get the crazy result
are gonna motivate the other 999
thousand and they'll be like i've had
people i've got women
they're like i hate cole he's a [ __ ]
prick blah blah blah and then
and then they actually got a hold of me
and they're like
yeah i i hated you at first and then
just fight you i did your diet just to
prove it doesn't work and i lost 10
pounds that are like i love you to call
after like
so end of the day it's about you've got
to be polarizing
if you're polarizing that's what'll get
the people to follow you that are going
to get the best result
and then you get such a crazy result
with somebody that's
morbidly obese that that result like the
before and afters
shock this because i get everyone to
take pictures they actually coach right
those before and afters will just
motivate the [ __ ] crybabies
because they can't dispute the result
they can hate me all they want
but it's like [ __ ] i hate cold but a
[ __ ] works they'll just do it
you know they'll just do it and that's
the thing you got to be polarizing
especially
in a youtube environment of a bunch of
[ __ ] [ __ ] too like that salt
number i told you
today like saying to put 2 000
milligrams in a liter like that
nobody's got the [ __ ] balls to say
that not one
[ __ ] keto promoter on youtube
has the [ __ ] like the guys that are
more mainstream
they do not have the [ __ ] balls to
[ __ ] say to pound back 10
000 milligrams on a day if you're low if
you're fat
they don't they're just like get in a
pinch of salt if you feel like you have
a headache it's [ __ ] they won't
they won't say to load up on it they
won't because they're scared
because they might they might be a
doctor and they're very smart and they
just
are chicken [ __ ] to go that distance or
they won't promote like
maybe the long fast or they won't
promote like a
very very high cholesterol fatty diet
for somebody
you know they just won't do it even
though they know it's the right thing to
do right
yeah i don't know who what kind of
people follow me but i've i've posted
some weird things i it's
so i get so little kickback it's amazing
like i did i did a um 12 day fast
a bit ago with salt water right
and i didn't get any like no one said
anything
isn't that weird like i don't know if it
follows me or they're just desensitized
or like beef girl
you know what's happened now so
i believe it was it was like i used to
be radical pumping long fast all right
but that's and then people now like you
get
fasting zealots get [ __ ] cheetos
zealots carnivores zealots vegan zealots
i use everything right i never
married to one thing but in the
beginning when i first started fasting
there was like nobody on especially
it was all hippies that were more
fasting for like
you know [ __ ] to see the [ __ ] holy
spirit or some [ __ ] or whatever you know
you know what i'm saying they were
fasting not for weight loss
but i was the first guy that like
pounded long fast and i had to do it
with this personality like
this [ __ ] character or else they
won't do it
so i had to fact shame the [ __ ] out of
them to get them to do it
i'm like you're a fat [ __ ] pig and so
like and then
and then like and then i showed him with
my own body i did the experiments and i
showed him results
and that's key and then they're like
okay this guy's
leader and he did it himself he
practices what he preaches then we'll
try it
and so then they did it but in the
beginning you've got to be
if you're trying to push a radical
something in the moment that's radical
like
say even fasting for three days at that
moment or seven days
you're never gonna be like a mainstream
doctor
could you please fast for seven days
can you please just try it [ __ ] that
doesn't [ __ ] work
right so then you get but then slowly
what happened
is it it got mainstream
because then like i was a little guy and
there was [ __ ] big guys copycatting
me in there like then
i'm promoting these crazy [ __ ]
fasting regimens like death fasting and
[ __ ] where you go drive fast and getting
a [ __ ] sauna and [ __ ] like i've done
i lost like 20 pounds in like 36 hours
doing that one but it was insane and i
kept like actually i
was dehydrated to be [ __ ] but i
actually lost a stupid amount of body
fat
like because but you gotta like if
anyone's watching this you gotta [ __ ]
watch what you're doing there you [ __ ]
kill yourself right you get crazy low
insult
but but anyway i was pushing stuff so
radical that they're literally pulling
my new tubes off because it was like
[ __ ] too [ __ ] hardcore you know
and then that's why my youtube channel
doesn't make a dime anymore nothing's
[ __ ] monetized now but i'm not gonna
i'm not gonna change i don't make [ __ ]
but i'm not gonna change the way i talk
because the end of the day youtube
doesn't
matter [ __ ] all of me anyways just it's
just a
place right i want to get the real stuff
though i don't wanna i'm not gonna
like sell out to to make a couple bucks
on a video and hold my language that
doesn't get any results
right but yeah so we got like you said
because you did 12 days at this point 12
day fast is
nothing crazy anymore like there's
[ __ ] people that have done like 60
days and [ __ ] and i had
i had a guy do a 16 i had a guy get a
hold of me that did a 16-day drive fast
like that's [ __ ] hardcore [ __ ]
and he did it because he's [ __ ] up and
you know he's got
like some serious he's not even way
overweight
he did that when he only had maybe 10
pounds to drop
like hardcore like i did a five-day
drive fast one time was probably the
hardest fast i'd ever
done because i went into that drive fast
probably like seven percent
body fat and i could barely walk up the
stairs after only five days dry
but i went into it so lean right
like not like some of these other ones
where i literally gained 30 pounds just
to do it that one i just
did it and this guy was crazy like 16
days no water or nothing
pretty hardcore so that's why you're not
getting so much backlash now because
fasting's all over the [ __ ] place and
i i'm sure it'll be
magazines out soon that'll even save
fasting on them
and it goes hand in hand with keto most
people that are actually smart
they're fasting most of the day they
need keto most of them
yeah what was the guy trying to heal
uh a lot of times uh
tumors uh skin fun like
really extreme skin problems [ __ ] dry
fasting works amazing
i had a woman that she got an infection
like on her ass cheek she got cut
and it wasn't getting bad after two days
she got a hold of me
and they wanted to give her a bunch of
antibiotics and i'm like i told her just
[ __ ] drive fast for three days and it
was
absolutely amazing how it just healed up
it was and it was like
the infection was going down her leg it
was so
it's just an extreme version of healing
and so you're not gonna go
[ __ ] start pumping iron on like a
longer dry fast you know you're not
gonna go
it's not what it's about so i'm trying
it but i have done dry fasting routines
myself i did a routine one time for a
whole month
where i drive fast in 48 hours every
refeed
and i was refeeding on like a normal
amount of meat
and just a pile of [ __ ] fruit like
basically a pile of like
not like watermelon oranges and [ __ ]
like that and i would
i was doing 48 hour drive fast and
exercising the whole way
and i like i've done uh i did a
a month where i did bacon and cucumbers
so i did like a kilo of bacon and like
two kilos of cucumbers every night at
about five
and i dry fasted all day and trained and
i
felt like a million bucks because i was
hitting that big huge salt load
and then the cucumbers i was hydrating
myself with cucumbers i wasn't drinking
any water
i didn't drink any water for a month i
literally just ate the bacon and ate the
two kilos of cucumbers i drank
like nothing like water like
maybe like a couple of liters in the
whole month
i just hydrated on cucumbers
that is so cool i believe that
now with all the [ __ ] [ __ ] and
all the stuff i've done i believe that
if you lived in somewhere
where you had really clean ocean water
i believe that you could basically live
with no fresh water
if you were eating some fruit
like just whatever orange is watermelon
and then your meat source
and you would basically be able to live
just with the ocean water and the fruit
that'll be enough water volume
very little water you need if you've got
ocean water and some fruit
because ocean water is a little bit
stiff because i looked at the ratios
and it's still stiffer than the 2000
milligram per liter sodium
but it ain't far off see i wish i i want
to do that experiment sometimes if i'm
at an ocean where it's clean and just
see
and just see how i feel on really stiff
ocean water
because i got a feeling that i'll just
piss out most of the extra sodium anyway
when you're balanced right
yeah that's actually really interesting
i wondered that too because i don't
generally do the uh 2000 milligrams per
liter
i i do a thousand uh milligrams in like
a cup like yeah um
and i don't and i find that if i drink
water that doesn't have salt in it now
i get dehydrated instantly i can't have
unsalted water
so sometimes like i'll it just you just
gotta learn your body but like you say
say if you put a whole teaspoon in like
just 250 mils
and maybe have a little bit of sips and
then you drink fresh water on the sides
as long as the ratio on the day is still
like where i'm kind of saying
like so you you know and then go back
just taste the urine if you can't taste
any salt
usually you'll feel like [ __ ] first
you'll feel like [ __ ]
and then you're like ah maybe i should
[ __ ] taste my urine like coal says
and then guarantee the urine doesn't
have no salt in it
right but like you can still like that's
why i say if someone's holding a crazy
amount of water
and they know they are like somebody
like some woman that's got
crazy water pockets on her body she
could like
get salt and very concentrated but if
she's going to do that
i would sip the concentrated solution
throughout the
like a few hours don't slam it because
then you turn it into a salt flush and
then just
[ __ ] your brains up you won't hold on to
the salt right you just won't hold it
it'll just go through you
so yeah but the best way to still get
sodium in is going to be
like if you're not like overweight or
whatever you're just
laying a fairly normal lifestyle like
you is going to be just getting as much
as you can with
with the meat you're eating right just
salt the [ __ ] out of that like put
a ton on it right and then i yeah and
that's what i would do
yeah and i don't know go ahead um
um can i go on the next question was
there more that you wanted to add to
that
well okay yeah go ahead no you go ahead
well with you i was just going to say
one thing about like that just kind of
brought up a point with with micro
dosing fruit
like when you have stomach problems like
yourself like if you're ever going to
try
to [ __ ] bring anything back in that's
how i've done it with people that i
threw on a strict meat only diet that
had gut problems or
or whatever health issues autoimmune
problems or whatever
i would micro dose some fruit back in
when i say
micro dose i'm talking like five
blueberries
or like five raspberries or like
like very small dosages that they
wouldn't react to and then they could
bump it up
if they were trying to get in like some
micros from fruit or whatever right
and that's how i do it so like like i i
won't ever have
anybody do strict carnivore forever i'll
always
try to bring them back to where they can
micro dose a little bit of stuff
and see if they can handle it yeah i've
actually managed to so i did
strict carnivore for
almost three years like two and a half
years uh like
nothing i did two years of nothing but
beef and salt and then
i started adding more meat and i've
managed to add in like
micro doses of fruit yeah it doesn't
seem to be doing anything i don't think
and that's what i do
so like my diet right now just because i
feel that
i feel that the healthiest like we're
just talking raw health not performance
like not explosive performance but i
believe like
the low carb routine i feel probably the
healthiest
so i'll eat basically fatty greasy salty
meat
and i'll mic and i'll on a small dose of
fruit but i might go as high as 100
grams
right but it's just not a lot i might
eat a grapefruit with like kind of with
a meal or something
or like some berries mostly that kind of
stuff
and that's how i do it right because i
think when i was doing straight i did
strip carnivore for about six weeks at
one point
and i felt good
for like the first you gotta remember
i'm like [ __ ] pretty
like i'm i live pretty hard and like you
know i
i sprint and i i i do a lot of exercise
and after about a month
it just felt like because i was only
doing it with steak like i wasn't doing
like nose to tail like i was eating
quite a bit of liver
i was eating quite a bit of liver but it
felt like i was just missing something
it wasn't like i was missing a pile of
carbohydrate but it was like my body
just
wanted that one [ __ ] orange and
that's all it needed to be
was just the smallest amount right and
then
it would have been fine it's always kind
of in the middle that perfect balance
it's always kind of in the middle there
that's why and i will do strict kettle
and sometimes people with cancer and
[ __ ] will be like strict right
really strict but you know i always like
just kind of play with that i'm just not
married to something because people
get so [ __ ] defined to something
if i could give you any advice if you're
trying to help people
just don't get married to a title
because people marry themselves or
they're eating strict carnivore
and now that's what they are and now
if they they're scared of the judgment
to go away from that even
slightly from their [ __ ] fan base and
i
get ridiculed all the time because i'll
go i'll tell people like the fat people
fast longer but then
the people that aren't as fat [ __ ] i got
people eating a couple meals a day some
days meal
mad two meal a day it depends maybe even
three meals a day if they're
radically on the top end where they're
eating like six thousand calories
that's three two thousand calorie meals
i'll still try to keep it in eight hours
i was doing that
i ate six thousand calories even seven
thousand some days for two weeks i've
shown people how to crank the metabolism
up really fast
by eating a lot and just burning it off
no matter what
and i was eating three 2 000 calorie
plus meals a day
like like essentially low carb like
that's you know what i mean that's
[ __ ] that's like who that eats that
much that's because i had to because i
was doing that much activity right so
yeah i'll link that video there's a
video on that i think that i've seen too
and that's when you were standing i
actually wanted to ask you about that
how do you
burn through that many calories so based
like my day what it looks like so say
that specific day if i'm like just gonna
go ham
i'll eat breakfast in my opinion
fasting like i'm fasted right now but in
my opinion
if you want the best performance eating
breakfast is important
like is number one because it cranks
your metabolism up right in the morning
so a lot of people if you do fasted
cardio
in the moment you may burn more fat with
fasted cardio in the morning
but on the whole of the day if you eat a
big breakfast you'll actually
burn more energy as a whole if you eat
the breakfast
because the breakfast lights the fire in
the morning and there's been actual
studies done on that
so i always the best result if you're
fat
is that you can eat a eat breakfast if
you can just stick to
breakfast until you get so lean
that you have to either eat breakfast
and a dinner
or maybe you eat one meal at like
four o'clock in the afternoon like
that's like me right now bite omad
like one meal i can't just do one meal
at breakfast right now because i'll just
[ __ ] run out of gas and i'll be
starving to death at night
so if i'm gonna do one that's a healing
day that's a rest day for me
if i fast in the morning eat at like
four o'clock and then
train but those hardcore days right like
7 000 cal
right away and i go bike for three hours
i just go for a regular and not a hard
bike ride
but i'll do a couple hills and i'll just
bike all over the
downtown by the river and [ __ ] in
edmonton for like three hours
i'll even go to one of the playgrounds
like because it's koba 19
[ __ ] i haven't even used the gym at all
i like i'm in the best shape of my life
right now just living like i did when i
was 16 years old with my buddies
cruising around on bmx's all day
and i just go to the park and i'll do
some pull-ups like just
hit a few hit a few pull-ups hang upside
down
just [ __ ] around i don't train anymore i
play i quit training and i started
playing again
i i try to become a kid again because as
soon as you get in that men
that frame of mind it's so hard to get
fat it's impossible
the only way a child can get fat as if
their parent is a [ __ ] idiot
a kid if you just throw the kid off the
cell phone and throw them outside the
kid
naturally because they're just so
playful by nature
they will be slim period a
kid will not be fat if you just chuck
them outside
they will not it's impossible it's
because the dopamine addiction from
sitting
so i'll just ride my bike go to the park
do a couple pull-ups nothing too crazy
like i won't fatigue
myself then maybe i'll come back and eat
that second meal
around one another 2 000 cow
do that and then bike around more maybe
take one of the fat girls for a long
walk
go to the park again maybe you had
another couple sets of push-ups pull-ups
or some exercises
um i might go walk some stairs for like
an hour just slow though right
i'm only i train like a farmer
i treat my day like i'm a farmer we're a
farmer
they're moving all day but they only
have a few intense moments like maybe
they gotta throw like a couple hundred
bales for two hours but then the rest of
their just kind of moving around milking
the cows and [ __ ] right
but that's how i treat it so i don't get
beat up and then i do that
every day and that's how i get that
crazy caloric burn
i'm not just going in like i'll go to
the stairs where i live
not even joking i'm not [ __ ] bragging
but i'll go to those stairs and i'll be
walking them stairs so [ __ ] slow
that people think that i've walked on a
treadmill at half a mile an hour and
people are asking me if i'm doing
therapy
and i'm walking backwards like so
[ __ ]
slow that's like what are you doing and
i'm the [ __ ]
rip [ __ ] on those stairs and all
everyone else is sprinting by me that
can they come and go every 15 minutes
and they're all fat because they're
trying to lose the weight yesterday
and they do not understand that that
little bit of intense work that they do
for
a half hour or an hour isn't a joke
compared to my whole day of movement
that i do
that's where people [ __ ] up they'll go
train way too intense
and either just completely deter
themselves from going to the exercise at
all because they're all beat up the next
day
or and they'll go home and just sit
there and watch a movie and eat now and
that's the problem
the way to lose weight is be a kid just
move all [ __ ] day
just so if it's you just move start with
not sitting and even the walking walk
slow
walk like you're not trying to get
anywhere see everyone's trying to get
somewhere
just [ __ ] walk like you don't even
give a [ __ ] like you're just kicking a
can through the bush
you know that movie shawshank redemption
yeah
you know when you know when andy first
like meets
red and he's in the he's in that yard
and he asks him if he can get him that
pickaxe
yeah and remember he's like
red says i liked him right away and it's
like he said he just kind of strolled
through and he's just flipping rods
like he's throwing hair that's the
attitude you need to [ __ ]
now that's the if you want to get ripped
and have a sexy body
that's the mentality don't try to get it
yesterday you just
live your [ __ ] life is what you end
up doing and just and if you've got
kids it makes it a joke like fat moms
are like oh you don't have kids cold oh
[ __ ] if i did i'd be even more ripped
like
what the [ __ ] how the [ __ ] do you fat
when you're a mom
you should be outside in the monkey bars
your [ __ ] kid you're [ __ ] useless
right like i don't even want to get
ranting about this [ __ ] [ __ ] because
i'll just get [ __ ] pissed off because
i see it all the time the kids are
already like their eyes are so [ __ ]
from being on their cell phone because
fat mom just
just gives them the phone to babysit
them right so the point is just play
you don't need to be in this strict
regimen i used to be that i used to
power lift competitively where it's like
this wait this reps this sets
but now healthy as i've been in years
since this virus because it made me i
couldn't be married to the gym anymore i
had to [ __ ]
i had to you know i had to compensate
for the gym i'm like what am i gonna do
when to the [ __ ] playground and it's
way more fun
you know and i just cruise around on my
bike all day and it's and that's it
okay i've got one last question um
so a number of people and i think these
are people who
have multiple health problems but
they've said that when they incorporated
fasting in particularly women
they've experienced things like hair
loss or loss of period
right have you ever seen that and you
know what that's caused by
yeah so the period can like it depends
so now
again it depends how heavy they are
because i've had times where
really obese women will have two periods
in a month instead of one
right so and then the hair a lot of
times
actually it's funny that's a good
question because i believe that
depends how long you're going that's why
i don't promote nothing longer than
seven days anymore because essentially
if you why go longer than that you're
committing metabolic suicide at that
point there's not one good [ __ ]
reason to pass longer than that there's
just not
you can get the health benefits from
doing 72-hour fats
right but salt the salt is low
i'm almost positive that's why all these
people because i seen
the same trend with people that water
fast like just plain water
there's women all over the internet that
lose a pile of [ __ ] hair on a plane
water fast
so i think as of recently because i
crank the salt
so hard now if the sodium is sky high it
comes back to
circulation and [ __ ] like just in the
scalp because when your sodium is high
if you're lean you'll see your veins
like pop out
like you literally are holding you're
gonna hold more blood volume and
circulation will be better when the
sodium's up so that's going to be one
thing for sure right
and then obviously if they're going it
just depends how lean they are if they
start fasting they're already skin and
bone
or maybe they're low muscle and they're
fasting
see this is where like the third i don't
want to [ __ ] get like
uh some girl that's got anorexia and
eating disorder like [ __ ] that's
i'm trying to get her to get to more of
a lifestyle where she's actually eating
every day trying to enjoy their life
because that's
that's all another issues there but yeah
that's the problem like it's gonna [ __ ]
with the hormones for sure
and sometimes they might lose the period
or get it back but don't
be afraid if the period gets [ __ ] up
because it'll happen
still fast and then the cycle will level
up
but it's like why are they fasting ask
themselves that
like why are they fasting that long
because if you're just trying to lose
weight
unless you're [ __ ] 300 or 400 pounds
there's not one good [ __ ] reason to
fast that long it's not even a good rate
seven days because i used to push like
pass yourself to the [ __ ] bone like
you're in a [ __ ]
nonsense concentration camp or some [ __ ]
but like
seven days that's enough right seven
days
tons of [ __ ] salt all right and then
if they
if they just do 72s they're not gonna
have any issues
right they don't need see this is this
is good because it gets to the [ __ ]
point where people get so
goddamn radical and then they just yo-yo
so like i've had so many people it's
clockwork the people that always do the
long fast
[ __ ] it up it's harder to do one meal a
day
that's harder for most people to eat one
[ __ ] meal a day
at for a woman let's say 1500 calories
like and and going low carb it's harder
for them to do that
continuously than it is to just buckle
down for a 14-day fast and then come off
that fast and completely [ __ ] it up
so that's why long fasting is [ __ ]
there's not one
good reason to do a long fast it's
longer than seven
there's still [ __ ] guys out there
that'll push 30 40 days and [ __ ] in 21
days
not one [ __ ] good reason any health
issue you do not need to
anything out there i could you could
heal with 72s
there's nothing you couldn't heal with
70 dudes lose the weight
get lean first if you're fat and you
have issues with your
metabolism [ __ ] move and lose the
weight
okay the thyroid problems because you're
a fat pig okay it's all
so if you're fat just focus on one thing
lose the weight
if there's another health issue like a
skin problem or a stomach problem
then maybe you would incorporate
something where you're doing like an
alternate day fasting routine to get
your your gut a rest right
like maybe a girl like you maybe you
would eat
uh i don't know if you could it depends
how much you can eat but maybe you'd eat
two meals every other day
or maybe if you really can eat like me
i've done 48 hour fasting routines right
smash back 5000 calories in one sitting
but i couldn't even do that now because
my activity is so high
to do that i'd have to eat like 10 000
calories on a daily
like and then the next day i'm not
eating anything i feel like [ __ ]
like i can't do that right so as far as
the food intake goes like calories and
food volume
it's based on activity if you if you're
crazy
like active you might have to eat more
often like you know you might have to
eat like i said
three 2 000 calorie meals and i'm really
cranking it but on an easier day
maybe it's one meal it's 2500. on a
moderate day
maybe it's two meals that are two
thousand a pop
that's probably my average would be 4500
calorie
two meals that are about 2500 or 125
once 2000.
breakfast and an early dinner or like
today a rest day where i'm probably
eat when we get off here and i might eat
3 000. so it's based on
never six meal a day little bitch-ass
meals it's always based on
if you're eating like like if you if you
start doing ultra marathon running
tomorrow and you're burning 4 000
calories as a small
woman well obviously you're not going to
eat 4 000 in one sitting
you'll break it up into maybe you know a
two thousand
and a two thousand you eat that much if
you don't low carb you could do that on
keto because
you can get quite a bit of food volume
in without feeling all bloated up
or you might even do three squares on an
eight-hour window you can still get a
16-hour fasting time man
on three squares of a girl your size i'd
eat three meals that were 1200 calories
a pop
that's a good sized meal 1200 at maybe
at
eight noon and four right and then
that's just on those hard days that
might be a day that you're going to run
like 10 miles
and then the next day you might just do
all that see it's all you just bounce
back and forth you're living a fasting
focused lifestyle
right one thing i don't do right now
because i'm just too lean and it's not
worth it
is i don't go two nights without food
because right now i'm just too lean so
if i like i don't skip a day right now
i'll only go all mad at most aggressive
just because
i'll lose sleep sleep's number one why
the [ __ ] would i [ __ ]
fast why would i do a 48 and and be like
oh this this might give me some or
36 i guess it might even be where you
eat like you know you might even say
sunday like at six one thing don't eat
before
bed ever always eat at least a few hours
before bed and then go like
for a long walk or burn it don't ever go
to bed with a gut full of food because
your digestive
digestive system heals at night that's
when your growth hormone goes up
a lot of these fasting people all
[ __ ] eat at night a big [ __ ] meal
don't do that it's always better if you
just eat at dinner time four or five
o'clock boat event at 10 that's okay
and burn it go to bed empty that's
really
important especially when you're trying
to lose weight actually
like people can lose weight on all that
eating right before bed but
you feel like [ __ ] you just you don't
feel as good you always want to go to
bed empty
right so
okay well we're out of time that was
really interesting and i really i'm very
entertained by your youtube videos and
one of the reasons that i got into these
extended fasts
it was out of curiosity because i
started doing omad and i was like
whoa i actually feel fine doing omad and
i was like well do i have to eat every
day and then i skipped a day i was like
well that's weird
so and then i looked up whatever on
youtube
and found you and you're screaming at
the camera and i was like
yes i will try that yeah
my youtube channel like some like if you
even look at my subscribers like
youtube just shadow down all my stuff
right
so like my subscriber rate used to be
like
high high like i haven't my subscriber
because they they'll actually
take them off like you'll just lose
subscribers they didn't unsubscribe you
just lose them
like they just take them off oh that's
crazy
yeah it's crazy but it doesn't whatever
it doesn't matter because the people
that do follow me
the results always cut through you know
yeah like yourself you're helping people
those results will always just cut
through everything like those
that's what counts just getting helping
people and
and essentially serving people
will make you happy really when you
start serving
you know and serving and helping people
lose weight or get healthy or whatnot
right like that's that's the main thing
but yeah like
back i was just gonna say that one last
thing there when i was saying don't eat
before bed but
when i left off that i think i was
talking about
yeah like you know you might have a day
where you do eat three squares and one
one day or but what i was gonna say was
about me with the sleep
that was what it was so because i'm lean
right now
for me to fast that second night and
just
and have the cortisol cranked up and not
be able to sleep great
that is not worth the trade of the
[ __ ]
little autophagy effect that i might get
for one [ __ ] night of fasting it's
not worth it
the sleep's number one right now that
being said if you're a badass
and you're going through withdrawals and
you're cutting coffee cutting sugar
and cutting meds and painkillers or
[ __ ] whatever you're on then yeah you
might not sleep you might not sleep for
worth of [ __ ] for three or four days
when you start your first fast that
you're gonna
do like a longer one right but i'm
talking once you are healthy
this is where people once you're healthy
you don't gotta [ __ ]
fast yourself to death all the time
because it's not like
people get so like like the the [ __ ]
followers get so radical as soon as you
say something about two meals a day
they're like that ain't healthy of
course it is
you make two [ __ ] squares with no
snacks
and you're burning it off and you're
athletic even three squares and you're
still getting in
like an old mad day a couple times a
week or
maybe you are throwing in a 48. what do
you think that's not a healthy [ __ ]
lifestyle like this is where people are
on
or nuts like they're they they get so
tied up in the fasting
they forget why the [ __ ] we're here
we're here to get healthy
and me specifically we're here to lose
[ __ ] weight i don't care about
like i still number one i just want to
lose the [ __ ] weight but i know from
experience of losing weight on a
caloric deficit on a month on a high
frequency eating routine like six meal a
day or five a day
that's terrible so that's out of the
question i won't forever promote that
but whatever's working as long as you're
losing weight that's the most important
thing to fix
first is just [ __ ] losing goddamn
weight but people always beat around the
bush with all these stupid other health
concerns right
but like whatever it takes whatever it
takes to [ __ ] get the weight off
that's what i always
and and like there's just so many
[ __ ] variables and routines and [ __ ]
but you're always fasting somewhat 16
hours
48 72 throwing a long one once a month
you know with the skin conditions dry
fasting works excellent for [ __ ] skin
problems
you know there's also i i [ __ ] talk
about urine therapy we didn't even get
into that but
i [ __ ] done it okay we might i might
have to have you back on and shoot you
with some more questions because i'm
really interested and
people don't hear about all the tests
like
help me say um i would
guess i'm classified as a health
influencer there's so many things that
i've tried that didn't work
it's hard to fathom and a lot of them
were
really awful um and i don't think people
hear enough about what doesn't work
because
people who usually tell you what works
they've tried a whole host of things
that
didn't work first and it's not pretty
there is one one just to close it up
there's like you know when we're talking
about
foods and like moderation and [ __ ]
there's definitely one food that
i believe yeah you can still get
diarrhea but it's very hard to overdose
on fat all right
like you can you know fat not like even
too much meat will plug you up
too much [ __ ] fiber from [ __ ] like
whatever fruit and vegetables like i
don't even eat any [ __ ] vegetables
anymore like
factual vegetables like because i
believe low hanging fruit was very
natural like who the [ __ ] would walk by
a raspberry and not eat it
yeah but like who the [ __ ] would walk
like kale everybody
like this that's just just a [ __ ]
scam as far as i'm concerned anymore but
if you want to eat and you feel fine go
ahead but it's i don't
feel that it's natural i feel that the
hunters would have got up in the morning
been maybe
mulching on a few berries during the
hunter and kill the big fat pig and then
eat the [ __ ] pig
like you know it's just it's right there
right now
i believe that where people like lived
i believe there's like okay for example
eskimos like they might have been
running like a strict
almost keto routine nose to tail but
does that mean that it was the best
because that's where they live
or was the best the [ __ ] biggest
toughest people that might have lived
right on the equator that had access to
everything and fought other tribes out
of that area because that area had the
best
possible food sources via berries and
meat you know
so but as far as healing the body as
soon as you start pulling back
like basic things like what you've done
like that's what i'll use like strict
meat only for
is definitely if people got some health
issues you know i know for a [ __ ]
fact
now as long as the protein is not too
high obviously you want to be true
you want to be keto macros that's where
people [ __ ] up carnivore you want to be
keto macros okay
20 80 or even less than 20 on the
protein i'm
i'm usually less on the protein than
that event like when
i do eat some carbs but if you're there
that is gonna be a very good starting
point for someone that's really [ __ ]
up health-wise for sure
plus the fasting and salt and then if
you start to heal
you start to heal up then just sprinkle
in a little bit of [ __ ] like
sprinkling maybe that little bit of
spice like cayenne pepper or a little
bit of berries or
maybe a little orange or something like
just like what you're doing right now is
perfect
that's how you and that's you take your
time because a lot of people [ __ ] it up
they'll go on a strict meat only diet
and then they'll feel good and then
they'll [ __ ] go eat
a pile of [ __ ] fruit and and they'll
just [ __ ] them up
well that didn't then they'll be
bad-mouthing the little bit of fruit but
it's because they just overdosed it's
called micro nutrients because you micro
[ __ ] dose them right yeah
yeah that's fair the other the other
place i see people screw up carnivore
all the time
is well my opinion anyways i
think if you drink milk all the time you
just gain
fat so people are like well i'm on like
a meat and a milk diet and i was like
how much dirt how much cheese are you
eating a day like a block of i'm
surviving off of cheese and bacon
and my health isn't improving it's like
yeah
like okay that's a good point because
honestly for all your listeners
you'll get a [ __ ] better result
eating [ __ ] spam
if you're trying to heal something
you're gonna be eating cheese and
[ __ ] melt
okay you can eat i got right now i even
made a video the other day
because at least the ratios with the
salt and the fat
with like store-bought sausages and spam
and bacon it's bang on
but as soon as you start eating all that
[ __ ] all that cheese and
especially the melts cooked like it's
not like you're sucking it off the cow's
tip it's not the same it's like
you know like people will still always
look for the [ __ ] easy road if you're
trying to [ __ ]
that carnivore it's like medicine even
strict
keto i treat it like medication
you know like i'm not gonna lie to you
i've had times where
i might just not eat any meat one day
just for shits and giggles and just
eat a bunch of [ __ ] oranges and
watermelon and fruit
and like just blast out a bunch of [ __ ]
or something i don't know
like just for an example like you might
pull protein for a day because it helps
your
your protein sensitivity go up which
fasting would do that just the same
but some people might just pull protein
and just eat everything else that they
would eat on the day there's
people do that right but it's medication
fasting is medication like you don't
need to overdo it
for no reason just because other people
are [ __ ] doing it
you know like i use strict keto like
with no [ __ ] plants or nothing that's
medication again like for
people that have massive [ __ ] sugar
problems or
extreme obesity you know it's very easy
to put somebody on straight bacon bacon
i like bacon because like i say it's so
fatty and so salty that even the [ __ ]
idiot that's 500 pounds of down syndrome
couldn't [ __ ] it up
where with the steak they still got to
make sure they [ __ ] had a bunch of
fat and add a bunch of salt
you know spams bang on spam's like 50
grams of protein thousand calories
high salt you go to hawaii if i went to
hawaii and just started eating spam and
just
was ripped i'd be like a [ __ ]
national celebrity because they love
family right
okay cool where can people find you
online apparently youtube is a little
hard but
where can they find you it's called
snake diet
and then instagram is snake diet wizard
so snake underscore diet underscore
wizard
um twitter i i don't like post stuff on
twitter through instagram but there's
stuff on there that snape died as well
and um yeah that's it and then the snake
juice package
they want to try that that's on amazon
and you can get it everywhere now states
and uk
and europe and so on and so forth and if
you want to just make snake juice don't
want to buy packets just
go on my youtube channel i got all sorts
all sorts of
there's older recipes but it all works
the basics is make sure you hit a
minimum on potassium the baseline and
make sure you have enough sodium if you
want to throw in some magnesium
throw in whatever we got there's boron
in those snake juice packets
because i felt boron was something that
we lack and it was easy to just throw in
a few milligrams of that in there
um and because i i read i learned about
borax
there's a whole [ __ ] conspiracy about
borax
how good boron is for your arthritis and
[ __ ] it's insane i've had people
as soon as they cut a bunch of sugar of
their diet and started getting the boron
in and like look from borax you only
need like
nothing like sprinkles of borax salt
and they sell the [ __ ] and store one
boron tablet is three milligrams boron
you can get three milligrams of boron if
you take one teaspoon
of borax put it in one liter of water
mix it up and one teaspoon of that
is three milligrams so how like and
they're selling that jar of 100 tablets
for like 30 bucks
literally i figured it was like a thirty
thousand to one markup it's unfucking
the downs are insane it's ridiculous
people gotta question everything
question everything you know but yeah so
that snake juice is there and then
um yeah that's basically oh and then
that's all my social media for the most
part just makes amazing instagram
youtube
facebook cole robinson oh i have a group
on facebook called
snake diet motivation it's the biggest
group
but it's shadow band and it's the one
you'll see it's all the accountability
posts right make people post pictures
like of their body when they start it's
got 230 000
members and to find it it won't be at
the top you have to dig
for it be the biggest one it's [ __ ]
yeah the ones that are copycat near at
the top
but you have to dig for it get on that
group and you'll see
like before and afters you'll see
because i i make people take starting
pictures and even get my help right or
else i just [ __ ] kick him with a curb
like
figure it out because i want those
starting pictures because that's what i
do i make people face the fear of
judgment
so it's like take pictures of your
[ __ ] ass post it publicly and like
[ __ ]
then get back to me and i'll give you
some help that's what i've done since
day one when i wasn't charging a dime
right i still help people for free i've
done donation
phone calls but i've ki washed that and
obviously don't have time but
i still have people come to me and ask
me for help and they're showing me that
they'll let me use their pictures and
stuff i'll always give people help if
they're showing me
that they're getting results via
pictures and let me put them up on
instagram
um i think after this if you're
interested i'll send you over a link
my dad created a well he's not he didn't
create it but he's part of a social
media
company i guess that doesn't have
restrictions
so you could upload things on that if
you just wanted a backup place
but it's pretty easy to grow followers
there right now
just because it's kind of just starting
i think there are 70 creators or
something
yeah it's good that yeah that's what we
need is more real like
nowadays the world's getting so [ __ ]
pussified that you can't say [ __ ] right
you know what
you know so you can't say [ __ ] yes
and even i know other guys that aren't
even nearly as vulgar as i am on videos
that just talk about fasting in there
and
i know one guy's for sure he's shadow
band because
as i was kind of growing my channel he
was about the same rate as me and
as soon as he got up to about this i
think i'm about 150 and he's about 150
it just stopped and he talks all the
time about fasting
and it just [ __ ] gets they just
[ __ ] got ki washed
so yeah because it didn't make any sense
yeah yeah no i should have like [ __ ] i
should have like three or four
thousand people on my [ __ ] because you
can just there's people that start
youtube channels
about me like literally like if you type
in snake dye there's people that just
make videos about the snake diet like
how the hell
does it make any sense i used to get 500
to 1000 subscribers like a day for a
while and then it just went to zero
doesn't make sense especially
when i'm making videos now and you see
my abuser
my view to like you know the ratio is up
there like my
time like my watch time is crazy high
like most people watch most of the video
usually right it doesn't make it but
it's okay because end of the day
it's awesome like he's doing that but i
my goal is to just pull off social media
eventually i want to just be like
i want to get very minimal of my life
and still help fat people but like
have them maybe on social media and i
coach them
and just just speak with results
it can really [ __ ] make a difference
after if there's enough of them right
so that was fun thank you cole
well thanks for having me on
[Music]
you